wir reißen nebenverdienst im krankenhaus
wird super bevor wir uns jetzt gleich
direkt das video anschauen würde ich
sagen wir haben wir erstmal kurzen blick
in die kommentare rott ist das scheiße
gespielt und trotzdem schaue ich mir
diesen müller je wie schlecht kann man
eigentlich noch schauspielern hätten wir
sinken hilf mir nichts neues bei uns ein
fall für luca junge da kann ich ja
besser schauspieler die ersten fünf
sekunden waren schon komplett verstören
gleich nach zehn sekunden würde luca
klatschend herumlaufen und das finden
wir jetzt mal zusammen raus warum ruhe
jetzt wieder da hat keiner was gesagt
wir brauchen etwas ganz anderes ein paar
sekunden später
jetzt gehts ja das ist eine komplett
normaler krankenhausaufenthalts was ist
denn hier für dich also erstmal muss man
sagen die musik war leiser als sie wie
sie reingekommen ist und geschrieben hat
aber ich bin gespannt ob er sie jetzt
ihre krankenschwester kollegin da im bad
entdeckt lecker drüber ging den kinder
auswaschen
wenn sich die kranken schwester lucy
beim mittagessen bekleckert ja genauso
gekleckert ich mich auch immer habt ihr
da draußen
und sie gehen allerdings begann diese
dort platz
denken sie an meine warnung ich hab sie
jetzt in black schwester hildegard hat
jetzt im blick ach du scheiße ich merke
schon wieder wie meine gehirnzellen
durch die ohren nach draußen abbauen
wollen jetzt kommt schon wir sind alle
das ist und da schreibt man halt machen
das ist kein alles nachsynchronisiert
[Musik]
weil ich dachte erst mein internet
spinnt und der hat irgendwie ton und
video und bisschen verzehrt aber das ist
alles nach synchron easy mein gott wir
sind doch alle befreundet jetzt mache
nicht so ein drama draus wirklich
deswegen ist hilfe meiner lieblingsserie
oh mein gott
ich frage mich ernsthaft ob ich das
überhaupt hochladen soll das ist ja
nicht normal alter reißt diese kranken
schwester lucy und die tanzt einfach für
jeden im krankenhaus ich denke wirklich
vor jeder folge sollte ich mir das jetzt
anschauen will ich mir das jetzt
anschauen nee mach ich es trotzdem ja
vielleicht ich werde mit dem oberarzt
was wir reden also ich weiß nicht was
ihr gerade denkt aber ich hab so ein
bisschen die vorahnung dass die lucy
dann auch noch für den oberarzt tanzen
wird um ihren job nicht zu verlieren
aber gut wir schauen wie wir gesagt das
wird konsequenzen haben und deswegen
spreche ich dir jetzt ein
warum
also lud sie ist jetzt tatsächlich
gefeuert worden ich bin aber gespannt
wie die jetzt darauf reagieren wird
sie bittet sie denn plötzlich war okay
also dein arbeitsverhalten was du ja am
tag legt es wirklich ja ist einwandfrei
professionell und klasse ich kündige die
rot frisst gras und ich erzählte ab
sofort hausverbot
ich habe nämlich erst gedacht hast dich
lucy dann immer noch weiter ins
krankenhaus kommen kann und auch für den
leute tanzen kann aber okay sie hat auch
noch hausverbot kleid hätte sie mal das
wort verantwortung kugeln sollen ein
lexikon persönlich kennen
junge der oberarzt hat ja richtig aus
die hildegard und die lose lieben und ok
krass also eher lustig wünschte
weiterhin viel erfolg in deinem tänzern
leben allerdings würde ich an dieser
stelle das heutige video jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde ganz ganz
ganz ganz viele von euch haben wir unter
meine letzte hilfe direkt schon vor
einer woche in die kommentare
geschrieben luca du musst auf dieses
neue krankenhaus video reagieren
ich wünschte ich hätte es nicht getan
weil ich meine reaktion gefallen hat
dann lass unter dem video einen daumen
hoch da und schreibt nochmal und in die
kommentare ein weiteres video auf dass
ich eventuell in einer woche dann
reagieren soll und weißt du noch keinen
teil der luxus sei dann abonniert gern
main kanal dadurch verpasste keine
videos mehr und hey abonnieren einen
kanal oder lucy kommt heute nacht in
dein zimmer und tanzt für dich
[Musik]